يفترشون الارض ويلتحفون السماء هنا صفاقس
التونسيه حيث لا حيله للمهاجرين غير
النظاميين سوى الانتظار ريثما تحين ساعه
النجده من هذه القوارب تبدا رحله تتضاءل
فيها فرص الحياه الوجهه ايطاليا لكن
العبور اليها قد ينذر بموت قادم ما زالت
تبكيه الامهات على الشواطئ
تتقاذفهم الامواج والبلدان فحتى قبل
ابحارهم يتناهى الى مسامعهم نبا التصدي
لقدومهم تونس تلك الدوله التي تشكو ازمه
اقتصاديه واجتماعيه بات يرهقها تدفقهم
مباحثات مشتركه مع زعماء ايطاليا وهولندا
والاتحاد الاوروبي تهدف الى تمهيد الطريق
لخطه انقاذ تونس ومعها كم المهاجرين هذا
اكثر من عشره الاف من الفرين والاعداد غير
دقيقه هكذا ترجح بيانات الرئيس التونسي
قيس سعيد بعد زياره مفاجئه لصفاقس التي
تعج بهم توسط فيها المهاجرين وبعد ان
استمع لبعض شكواهم اوضح ان بلاده ليست
بوابه حدوديه لاوروبا ولا يمكن ايضا ان
نقوم بالدور الذي
يفسح عنه البعض ويخفيه البعض الاخر بان
نكون حراسا
لدولهم لا الحل لا يمكن ان يكون الا
انسانيا وجماعيا بناء على مقاييس انسانيه
ولكن في ظل القانون
مشتركه لحل واحده من اطول الازمه السياسيه
داخل الاتحاد الاوروبي وذلك بعد التوصل
لخطه مبدئيه لتقاسم مسؤوليتهم لكن قد تكون
رئيسه الوزراء الايطاليه جورجيا ميلوني
التي زارت تونس مرتين في اسبوع الطرف
الاشد في منعهم من ان تطا اقدامهم بلادها
اسراء الصغير العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات